great so welcome back
um our next speaker is Jacob steinhardt
he's an assistant professor of
Statistics here at Berkeley
cool uh thanks yeah sorry about the
technical difficulties but I think we
have things uh set out today uh so I'm
going to be talking about some recent
work uh with my student minajison and
collaborated Kiel Garg on supply side
equilibrium recommending systems so just
to kind of set the stage here
um the kind of motivation is that a lot
of content these days is digital it's
kind of distributed uh over the internet
and this distribution is mediated by
recommender systems such as Netflix uh
Spotify things like this and so there's
kind of these recommended systems create
a kind of marketplace
where producers are competing with each
other to be recommended to users so
they're trying to create the content
that will be uh most recommended and uh
this Marketplace induces a bunch of
competitive effects so an example is you
know for instance on YouTube people
often create very Salient images as the
kind of Splash image to try to get
people to click to some extent the
recommended system actually you know
kind of explicitly promotes that to some
extent this is just what kind of causes
users to click on things uh you'll have
uh hooks in songs to try to get people
to keep listening to them because of
sort of how the pricing model and
Spotify Works um and so there's all of
these kind of strategic effects that you
get from these recommending systems and
in this talk
um I'm going to be focusing on one
particular effect which is the emergence
of genres or in some cases where you
already had genres of the emergence of
uh micro genres so
um
so as an example you know in movies
where I guess use to genres like you
have kind of
um you know action movies comedies uh
things like this but once you have uh
things like like Netflix that are making
very personalized recommendations
there's even some evidence of getting
even more fine-grained genres so
particular you know styles of say
romantic comedies that uh cater
particular to particular users and so we
kind of want to understand this and so
I'm going to present uh maybe the sort
of simplest uh possible but still fairly
interesting theoretical model that
allows us to kind of get at this effect
and then try to understand uh Nash
equilibria in this model so here's uh
the kind of formal setting that we're
going to consider we're going to imagine
a setting where we have end users U1
through un uh each user we're going to
represent as a vector that denotes uh
essentially their preferences right so
in the movie regime maybe the user has
like some preference for really good
cinematography some preference for you
know action scenes some preference for I
don't know like Tom Cruise being one of
the actors or maybe a preference against
it I don't know although although in
this case we'll assume that all
preferences are at least a non-negative
linear combination of uh of the
attributes so each user has this
preference vector and then in addition
there's going to be P producers and for
Simplicity we'll assume each producer
creates just one good so you know maybe
you have a conglomerate that produces
lots of movies but we'll think of each
team as you know some mini producers so
each producer produces one good so they
uh they're actually strategically so
they're choosing content and will denote
the content that producer uh Jay
produces as PJ which is also going to be
this non-negative Vector in Rd and so
the value that a user assigns to a given
piece of content is just given by the
dot product between these two so between
the user's preferences and the
attributes
um and so we'll also just assume that
our recommender system is actually
perfect so it always assigns uh a uh
user the good that has the most uh
similar content so the thing that would
produce the most value to them so uh
this is pretty simple but there's
already some Key properties that kind of
depart from many classical models of
economic competition uh so the main one
is that we have this very high
dimensional decision space right because
each producer is actually picking some
multi-dimensional Vector in Rd
typically uh models of kind of
competition would often either have uh
choices from some finite Choice set or
if you have something continuous it
would be some one-dimensional quantity
like price there's some exceptions like
uh hotel and style games where you might
be choosing locations but even those end
up being fairly different we'll see from
this model the other thing is that you
have this heterogeneous user base right
so users have not just multiple types
but could kind of be at any point in Rd
and if we care about things like genre
formation then we're going to need to
model the fact that you know different
producers might cater to different users
and so then this conflict kids things
because we need to consider at least
some sort of asymmetric user behaviors
at equilibrium where you know not
everyone is doing the same thing
so uh I guess the final part of this
model is we need to talk about uh
producer cost and profit right so a
producer could just kind of win by
taking the norm of their Vector to
Infinity right because this will make
the dot product big this is obviously
not what we want and so we model this by
saying that you know there's some cost
to producing content so in particular
you know I can't just make everything
good at once for free I'm going to you
know take some Norm so this could be L1
or the L2 Norm whatever you want and
I'll raise it to some power uh generally
this power should be bigger than one
because we want to uh you know encode
the fact that it's kind of increasing
marginal cost to competing along every
Dimension at once I can't just like be
good at everything or maybe I could but
in those cases we shouldn't expect
interest in Behavior we should just
expect kind of a single genre because
you just want to be good at everything
at once
um and so with all of these put together
the profit function is the following so
the profit that producer Jay gets if uh
conditional on what all the other
producers do in the users is going to
just be the number of users that they
win so we'll assume that it's something
like a movie where you're selling things
at some fixed cost minus the cost of
production
um since this is a digital good this is
a one-time cost because we imagine
there's a kind of large upfront cost
reduced content but it's then cheap to
duplicate or distribute so this is the
overall model
um so are there any questions about uh
about this model before I kind of go
into results
so there's a question online that I'll
read out it says how do you tie break
between producers okay good so
um is going to turn out that the
equilibria will investigate don't really
have ties at least with non-zero
probability uh but if you did have to
tie break we would just pick randomly
among uh all of the possibilities uh
yeah good good question
uh any others
uh yes
um so in terms of the producer cost
function what exactly are the features
meant to represent and why are you
taking like and you know
this idea they can make it arbitrarily
large rather than just by bounding the
the norm right so there's a couple
there's a couple different settings
where we would kind of have this cost
function representing different things
so in the movie case it would basically
be you know like different axes along
which a movie could you know be good so
like things like cinematography like
plot uh I don't know like the actors
themselves things like that
um and so then you know the sense like
the reason why you would imagine things
are super linear is like a film only has
like so many minutes so you kind of have
to decide what you're going to focus on
um another example might be if say you
are I don't know just say just
recommending content to people then you
might be able to kind of have better
content if you've collect like if uh
let's see I don't want to put this so
basically like you imagine you might
have like different amounts of if we
want to kind of model an imperfect
information setting you can imagine you
have like different amounts of data
about each user and or each user type
and the more data you have about a type
kind of the higher quality you know
content you're giving to that user
um and so then the cost is going to be
something like the cost of you know data
collection
um so that might be another another
example yeah
uh yes Deb can I ask a quick question
I'll show you uh should the course I
mean or what properties of the cost
function are you going to use going
ahead uh I'm basically just going to use
that it's
an oil a power of a norm so the reason
for that is at some point I'm going to
want to take a dual Norm
um and it turns out that oh sorry have
you thought about like using some audio
functions because it does seem in this
context the costs would be diminishing
returns
so once you have Tom Cruise and you have
good cinematography the rest doesn't
matter so much
um well so that would be in the I guess
so I think that would be more about the
user utility
um so the cost the cost is like the cost
of production
um so I think you're saying like once I
have a couple good things then uh maybe
there's like diminishing returns to more
good things uh so I agree that's kind of
a limitation here that would be more in
uh kind of this part where we're
assuming linearity
um so I I think I would basically agree
with that um I guess I just say you know
these linear things uh got us pretty far
historically so the net you know the
original Netflix challenge was mostly
won by linear things
um so I think later people realize you
do want to add non-linear effects
um so we're basically not doing that
here but I kind of agree with your point
uh yeah my question was around uh the
number of users one so they're either
like one or lost I'm curious if you guys
thought about
um like maybe like number of minutes
watched or just like more of like a
functional relationship between you know
the degree to which uh you have a user
kind of bought in and if that matters it
might not matter for profit I'm curious
actually yeah so I think
um
like you could you could do that
um
trying to think how it would like change
any of our results I guess
um well so one thing is that actually
the like discontinuity here kind of
complicates the study of equilibria
because even establishing existence is
kind of tricky so it might actually be a
bit easier to analyze things if if you
had more continuous metrics um on the
other hand it also you know makes the
math a bit harder because you have to
kind of account for that
um
my guess is that it doesn't change the
story a ton but I think
yeah I need to I maybe I shouldn't say
that because I need to think in a bit
more detail um but basically yeah I I
think this is a thing you should you
should consider doing and basically
we're just trying to make things as
simple as possible so we started with
this uh yes sorry I guess just related
to the last question
hi uh as I guess related to the last
question if I understand correctly can't
you just like treat each user as like a
user minute instead like let's say each
eye is a minute of a specific user and
they just create a lot of duplicates or
something
or maybe then and will blow up two big
and somehow that's better
I think you can do that if you
model dependencies between the minutes
issues like you might think that like if
you've watched for a while you might
stop at some point
um so you could probably model some
effects that way but I think probably to
get at like Deb's full point you need to
have uh have some dependencies okay
thanks yeah would it be straightforward
to say that users just choose
proportional like they sample an item
proportional to their Christian
similarity
yeah so you can also do this like having
a soft Max instead of a hard Max in fact
um there's some concurrent work uh by
other people at Berkeley
um Carl Kraus and uh and some other
people who I'm blinking on I'm sorry I
should have included the citation here
but um yeah basically uh you can do this
uh
uh oh Sarah Dean's one of the other
people but but anyways you can do this
it kind of leads to a different analysis
um I'm probably not going to get this
out of that talk but that's another
possibility
um oh yeah maybe one last question that
I wanted oh does this seems beginning at
the distinction between a user enjoying
content versus actually getting shown by
the recommender system in the first
place which seems to be
yeah so I guess we're yeah we're not
making that distinction right here
um I guess partly because we're assuming
that the producer is perfect um but if
we're in perfect you'd want to do that
um okay these are great questions but I
just want to go on since I'm on slide
three of of 15.
um okay um uh so let me just like tell
you about some of the things that can
happen in this setting uh so I guess
first let's just take like the simplest
case uh D equals one n equals one user
uh so we just have like one dimensional
preferences what this means is basically
there's just like one axis of quality
all you care about is like how high the
quality is what's gonna happen
um well
I guess the first thing you realize is
that question about ties starts to
matter now because there's kind of it
turns out actually there's like no
pure strategy equilibria here why not
well uh basically you're going to you
know play the highest uh you know who
it's basically like whoever plays a
higher number wins
um and then if you're not so if you play
the higher number then uh you know
you're happy but if you played the lower
number then you'd like rather just play
Zero because there's some cost of
production right so like you don't want
to play point nine if your opponent
plays one so
if you had 0.9 and 1 the 0.9 would like
to play Zero but then the one is like
man I really didn't want to play one
because I could have won by just playing
point one
um but then you know you're just gonna
have been a cycle if they're down at
point one uh you're going to go back up
to point two and you might think okay I
can fix this with ties
but the problem is with ties then maybe
like both people play 0.5 or something
but then if either of the 0.5s went up
to point six they're suddenly winning
again so Ty like having ties and
Randomness that ties doesn't really fix
this
um so there's actually no even
asymmetric pure strategy equilibria here
and so you need a mixed strategy
equilibria and
it actually turns out once you're
willing to have mixed strategy
equilibria you can have symmetric mixed
strategy equilibria so we can actually
assume everyone plays the same random
strategy I said we need to somehow have
you know some sort of asymmetry in what
people do and so the nice thing here is
actually the asymmetry is going to come
out in the realization of that
randomness and so you'll be able to get
genres by you know looking at the
support of this mixed strategy
equilibrium and seeing that the support
you know has different directions and
higher dimensional settings each of
those directions is going to be one of
the genres so this is kind of this nice
thing that uh actually even though we
have to study asymmetric phenomena which
are often quite challenging we can
actually get away uh with symmetric
things as long as we're mixed and we're
kind of forced to be mixed because of
this discontinuity uh so having said
that let's just talk about what actually
happens in this one dimensional setting
before kind of going into all of that so
you have a unique symmetric mixed
equilibrium
the CDF is this kind of power law so uh
the probability of being you know less
than equal to some value P grows as P to
the beta over P minus one so this means
it's going to uh grow uh more kind of
super linearly as beta increases less
super linearly as P increases and so you
get kind of Curves uh like this uh so
say this this is for people's two
producers so if we have two producers uh
beta is one then it turns out both
producers just pick this uniform
distribution as beta increases then they
kind of go more towards kind of uh
playing pretty close to one
um why is that well because you can
actually be pretty close to one before
you start in Korean costs so you might
as well be there but there's still this
kind of randomization and so
um and so here producers are just
Computing on quality okay so this is
kind of the simple warm-up setting um so
are there any questions about what's
going on here
how am I doing on time I have like 20
minutes yeah 20 25 okay yeah great
um okay so let's see what happens in
higher Dimensions because actually even
in two Dimensions you get something
pretty interesting so the 2D example
will assume there's two users
they're either one zero or zero one so
basically user one only cares about the
first property of the content user two
only carries over the second quality uh
property and we'll assume that there's
two producers so
one of two things intuitively we might
expect one of two things intuitively to
happen one is that uh it turns out that
it's kind of Cheaper to just be good at
everything at once and we should just uh
kind of you know everyone should compete
to make both producers happy or you
might think that what's going to happen
is that you know one person goes after
one producer one person goes after the
other I guess to keep that as like a
mixed strategy equilibrium then this
would have to be kind of like a
superposition of these two lines
um it turns out this is sort of what
happens but not quite so for small
values of beta for beta less than or
equal to two uh taking the cost function
to the L2 Norm you end up with a single
genre
now this kind of makes sense right
because like let's think about what
happens if beta is like 0.5 or say 1.5
right then your cost is going to be like
P1 squared plus P2 squared to the 1 over
or sorry to the
uh
uh 1.5 over 2.
and so you know this is kind of like
additive
across the two Dimensions but then
you're taking it to some power that's
less than one so it's basically saying
that costs are sub-editive across
Dimensions so actually like the more
you've done on one dimension the less
the cost is have been earlier mentioned
so it actually makes a lot of sense that
you know you would only compete on one
genre and so really it's like beta
bigger than two that is kind of the
interesting regime here and so uh in
that regime you actually end up with
support that is on uh a circle of some
fixed radius so it's still one
dimensional support uh there's
interestingly infinitely many genres uh
although you can kind of see like
uh it is kind of like mixing between
these two directions and then the final
thing is that you can also look at the
profit that the producers get at
equilibrium so normally in a competitive
market in sort of traditional models of
competition if you even have two firms
at equilibrium uh you should have zero
profit but here because of the sort of
heterogeneity of the users this isn't
true anymore
basically intuitively
if I expect kind of that I'm going to go
after one user about the other person
might go after the other user I'm
actually not incentivized to like give
all of you know my Revenue back as value
to the user like I should actually be
able to get some profit because there's
some chance that I'm not competing with
anyone and so that's actually what we
see here uh at exactly the phase
transition where you go this isn't true
in general but in this case at exactly
the phase transition where you go from
this kind of single genre equilibrium to
this infinite genre equilibrium you go
from zero profit to non-zero profit
um okay so any questions about what's
going on in this two-dimensional case
uh yes does it collapse down like
there's some point where it goes from
this line to the other direction does it
collapse to a point at some point in the
middle but
so you mean like say as a number of
producers increases even for the for
this case I mean sorry oh I see you're
saying is it like a stark transition or
not
yeah yeah so what happens is that when
beta equals two there is actually many
Nash equilibria
okay which include both the line and the
circle
when beta is less than two there's only
one Nash equilibrium and when beta is
greater than two
I think we did we prove this I'm pretty
sure there's only one when beta is
greater than two as well or certainly I
believe that I don't remember whether we
proved that or not but this is like sort
of what you should think of the picture
as being
uh cool uh
okay let me also maybe make one other
point uh which is about how
this kind of changes
as we increase the number of producers
so I showed you what happened when there
were two producers
but you can actually have a kind of
well I I think it's useful to just
understand what happens as a number of
produces increases so when there's two
producers you have this equilibrium
that's like uh supported on this quarter
Circle here here I'm not drawing the
density I'm just drawing the support
um you can compute the density but just
for Simplicity uh we're just looking at
what the support looks like so it's
always one-dimensional
um once you have three users actually
now the support is like this line and
then it becomes convex as you have more
users and what happens is that as the
number of physics goes to Infinity then
you actually end up having this like
more and more convergence towards the
coordinate axes so this story about how
you know maybe people should just uh
compete for one user or the other
it okay so when that turned out not to
be true when there were only two
producers but once you have like really
a perfectly competitive market where
there's instantly many people competing
then you actually do end up uh with
things on the coordinate axis and it
actually converges to like the sort of
uh strategy like the realization of what
you see converges to this sort of
poisson process and uh
I guess I can kind of show that here
um so actually maybe before I say uh
yeah maybe before I go to the song
process I guess the other kind of
interesting thing you could ask about is
what happens as uh we pick kind of like
user preferences that are like more
aligned with each other right so instead
of taking like two users that are
orthogonal where like they each care
about totally different things what
happens if uh they're kind of more
aligned
um we'll get to like the formal
statements about that later but
basically what happens is that this like
critical value of beta where you switch
from single genre to multi-genre uh in
sort of uh increases because there's
kind of more incentive to kind of cater
to both people at once if they're more
similar
um
foreign
so what I'm showing here I guess is this
poisson process for kind of different
possible alignments between the users so
uh this is the case where you have uh
two
users that are orthogonal uh as as I
kind of said what happens is that all
producers will either be on you know the
x-axis or the y-axis
um this purple curve here that you can
kind of see shows you like the CDF along
this axis
and then if things are kind of less
orthogonal you actually get these like
really goofy equilibria that are like
piecewise constant it's we're like
really surprised this happened actually
it took us like
like
embarrassingly long to work out uh that
this was the answer but you get these
equilibria whose uh CDF is actually like
piecewise polynomial and also supported
on two lines but the two lines are
actually not uh exactly the uh users uh
themselves so what happens is that you
kind of get lines that are like a little
bit in the interior of the user vectors
um so sorry that might have been a bit
of a mouthful but this is just to like
illustrate that you actually can get
like pretty interesting phenomena with
these equilibria
um yes in the back uh what for amateur
is very in the first three so oh good
good great question so can you repeat
the question please
uh the question was what parameters
varying in the first three plots so
um
the thing that is varying is the angle
between the two users so before I guess
this was the thing I was saying about
user alignment so before we were
assuming the users were like the like
one zero and zero one but now I'm taking
the users to actually be I guess given
by these uh the black vectors here so
here they have an angle of like pi over
4.3 between each other here they have an
angle of pi over four between each other
okay they have an angle of pi over 3.5
between each other
um
there's a fixed value of beta I forget
what what beta value we use to generate
this but basically beta is fixed and
this like angle between the users is
varying and we're seeing how this
affects what the producers do
uh yes in the back
um can you give any intuition for why
these pieces show up like what explains
to this yeah
uh
so
I don't have great intuition I guess as
evidenced by the fact that it took us a
long time to figure this out
um it's possible that Mina has better
intuition than me I guess one thing I
can say is that these are exactly
orchestrated so that the uh projection
onto one Axis or the other is exactly
like it gives you a disjoint Union
that's exactly everything
um it seems like somehow that ends up
there's some math that like kind of
tells you that you should want that to
happen I don't know intuitively why you
should want that to happen
um but I think yeah kind of intuitively
what's happening is like the equilibrium
is trying to cover each user
individually kind of exactly once
uh yes
um and and sorry maybe just to clarify
so you said this is
uh you said you mentioned something
about a poisson process can you is that
in this picture and if so can you
explain yeah so
yeah so basically uh what happens is p
goes to Infinity so basically with
probability approaching one so for any
fixed producer with probability of
protein one they just pick the zero
Vector they kind of have to do this
because if if the probability of picking
something non-zero was not like
Vanishing then basically everyone like
you know infinitely many people are
trying something only two of them can
win then everyone's getting like
negative profit almost certainly and
that that kind of doesn't work so it has
to be the case that from the perspective
of any fixed producer uh you're going to
uh get uh you're going to be like zero
almost always so the distribution I'm
showing instead is the Winner's
distribution what I mean by this is like
conditional
on winning one of the users
so conditional on being one of the you
know two people that are like uh getting
one of the users uh what is your density
um and that corresponds to
I think there's a way to like relate
that to the like also limiting I guess
the other thing you could have done as a
limit is to kind of like look at what
everyone you know plays and then see
what measure that uh limits out to and
this is kind of pretty closely tied to
this Winner's distribution
um great any other questions
okay so let me jump into like like these
are kind of examples but let me jump
into some more uh general theory
so
uh okay right so the kind of two
phenomena that I want to characterize
here the first is when you get uh kind
of Zero versus non-zero profit actually
we'll get to that later the other one
that is what we're going to cover first
is where this phase transition happens
so when do we go from like one genre to
more than one genre
so it turns out that actually we can
like exactly characterize when you'll
have one genre and one you'll have more
than one genre so uh there's uh it's
going to turn out to be related to like
The Duality of a search optimization
problem so I I need to set up a bit of
notation to kind of tell you what's
going on here so basically uh we're
going to let uh this given a producer P
we're going to let y of P be basically
the vector of realized user values uh so
that like u1p is like the value of P to
use or one uh u n is the value of P to
user n except I'm going to raise them to
the power of beta
um so this is now this kind of like
slightly weird non-linear function
and I'm going to define the set s beta
to just be the image of the unit Norm
ball
uh of this y of P function
so basically I'm you know taking
everything in the unit fall I'm looking
at the values that the users get from
that I'm going to raise it to the beta
power element wise
so uh the theorem is that you basically
get more than one genre
exactly when the convex hole of this set
is kind of large compared to the set
itself so if we let S Bar beta be the
convex all of s beta then all symmetric
equilibria are multi-genre if and only
if the following holds that the maximum
of the sum from I equals 1 to n of log y
i over this uh convex hole is strictly
bigger than the maximum uh of the sum of
y i over s beta itself so this if s beta
was already convex then certainly you
would have equality here so this k then
everything would have to be a single
genre that's kind of why I say like for
instance this would imply for like the
L2 Norm uh
uh uh actually I was gonna say something
false but in roughly it would imply
for like say the lp Norm or say the lq
norm that if beta is less than or equal
to Q then you know you're going to have
strong Duality
um there's a slight wrinkle there but
this is basically true
um and then you know in general even if
it's not convex sometimes you might have
strong Duality uh and so it's really
when this doesn't hold that you get uh
that you're kind of uh get multiple
genres so this is the result I guess a
few things that are worth noting here so
um this can actually be computed
efficiently because uh we're taking log
of y i right so even though there's this
beta here once I'm taking logs that like
falls out and it's just a linear term so
this I can compute efficiently this is
not clear can compute efficiently it is
maximizing a con k function over a
convex set so there's some hope but it's
not like trivial to generate 12 linear
separation Oracle for this convex set so
uh you can't it's I think is actually a
somewhat interesting computational
question but it's at least not obvious
if you can compute this quickly
the final thing is that this
function is actually the like Nash
welfare for those of you who are
familiar with bargaining in theory so
it's kind of interesting that uh this
competitive equilibrium gives you
something similar to a bargaining
solution
uh just to give some intuition about
these sets as beta so
if we took uh you know these uh this
like simple setting from before
um one zero and zero one as the two user
vectors then here's what s beta looks
like as we change beta so it starts out
uh looking like this circle then it
becomes this triangle and then
eventually it becomes concave and this
green thing is the difference between
the convex hole and the set itself
um and then as you get vectors that have
like a smaller angle between them then
the point at which you kind of you know
depart from your convex hole actually
happens later and so this is like part
of the intuition in this theorem that
the more vectors are kind of pointed in
the same direction the more you should
expect to have a single genre
equilibrium oh yes uh so you talked
about the two extremes of one genre and
infinitely many are there any regimes
where you see sort of finitely many but
greater than one
yeah so
um
if you have
only two users
then the only time that can happen is
with infinitely many producers in which
case you have two genres so basically in
the two user cases there's like three
things that can happen one two or
Infinity
um and you and like you can actually
prove this
um for more than two users I think it's
less clear I mean I guess my conjecture
would be that
if you have end users then the number of
genres is probably
either an in like either between one and
N or infinite
um but I this is like I take this as
like a somewhat tentative conjecture but
this is what I believe should be true
but I I think we really don't know right
now
um okay uh so
I guess you know if you're not happy
with these kind of complicated sets
there's also some sufficient conditions
that are kind of more directly in terms
of just like norms and stuff that we're
used to uh so one corollary you can get
out of this is if you define this
quantity Z which is just uh the sum of
the uh normalized user vectors under the
Dual Norm of whatever Norm you're using
then I'll equilibrium multi-genre as
long as Z is less than n to the one
minus one over beta
um so I guess first of all kind of
trivially Z is less than or equal to n
because each of these vectors is like uh
unit norm and we're adding them up so my
triangle inequality is at most n it'll
be exactly equal to n Only If all of the
users are identical so that sort of
saying if they're all identical you're
definitely going to be single genre if
they were orthogonal or random then Z
would be something like root n for the
L2 norm and so then you're saying like
when beta is like two plus level of one
you're going to uh have uh you're going
to have these multi-gener equilibria
that's kind of the smallest you would
hope for kind of for this reason we said
before and so uh you know in between you
get something in between
um I guess I kind of mentioned this
already sometimes Spade is just like
convex no matter what the users are in
particular for LLP Norms if you listen
or equal to p
um
I guess the other thing I wanted to
mention is this kind of producer profit
thing right so we had this interesting
phenomenon where producers can achieve
non-zero profit it sort of seemed
related to the original genres so can we
formalize this uh we can in in
some sense so I guess first I can give a
general sufficient condition for
positive profit although
um it's not clear if this is as tight as
this Z condition I gave before but we
can say okay let Q be the maximum amount
that any producer can align with all of
the users right so basically I want I
want a producer that is sort of
simultaneously having High Dot product
with every user at once
um because I'm taking this Min here
so here if Q is less than n to the
negative p over beta the expected profit
at equilibrium must be strictly positive
uh this is you know Q is always going to
be strictly less than one unless all of
the users are fully aligned
as beta goes to Infinity p over beta
goes to zero so the right hand side will
approach one and so in particular for
sufficiently large beta you'll always
get strictly positive profit
um
so uh the kind of overall interpretation
here is that if users are more spread
out Q will be smaller it'll be easier to
get profit yep
um another more direct connection
between genres and profit is that
multiple genres are actually necessary
for positive profit so uh if uh some
equilibrium mu is a single Atomic
equilibrium then all producers actually
receive zero expected profit at that
equilibrium another thing you can show
that kind of uh just follows from a
symmetry argument is that the profit
if there's n users and P producers it's
always at most n over P so also as the
number of producers goes to Infinity
actually profit gets driven down to zero
um so that's pretty much everything I
have so just to summarize we created
this uh fairly simple model but that had
these two Key properties of high
dimensionality and heterogeneity these
are already enough to give you like
pretty diverse and interesting phenomena
I really think I think there's just like
a lot to study here right I mean like I
think these results are interesting but
I think it's like really just scratching
the surface of of what's going on here
and so there's a lot more that we could
understand so you know I'd be very
interested to chat with people who would
be interested in uh in thinking about
this more
um we kind of have these two resulting
phenomena of genres and positive profit
and I think there's just like many open
questions even even Beyond these you
know understanding not just the uh
producer profit but how user utility
depends on say the number of producers
or things like that and then some of the
questions that you all are bringing up
at the beginning of this talk
um right what happens with the
recommendations are noisy
um can we like generally characterize
the shape of equilibrium support
um what happens if like people are like
like learning in these equilibria rather
than you know just like get into it
right away um so I think there's a lot
to study here
um I think I'll end there and take
questions
um have you considered the setting when
they're different weights to the users
for example signifying that your user
subpopulations might have different
numbers of members in them or other
settings where like maybe like clusters
of users who are kind of similar to each
other and uh I'd be really interested to
know how that impacts genre formation
yeah
um so
let's see what can I say there so uh you
can basically incorporate weights here
by just you know like if I have if I
want like 30 of the users to be from one
and seventy percent of the other I can
just have like point three n for 1.7
from the other I mean really I guess
what you probably want is like a user
distribution rather than just a finite
set
um I think uh to your question
we don't understand a ton about the
cluster thing it was actually one of the
earlier things uh we were interested in
but then even like this two user case
ended up being quite mathematically
challenging
um
I think
you know these like
I guess like these kinds of theorems on
like uh
on genres it turns out like this is kind
this has stated as kind of weak for the
case where you have two clusters but
there's a kind of improved uh like an
improved result that tries to get at
cluster structure so I think we know a
little bit about like this kind of
cluster structure with like one versus
more than one but I think we know very
little about the shape of the
equilibrium I think like most of that is
just totally open
uh yeah yeah I'm curious how much uh
because this is for uh like media
distribution platforms like Spotify and
Netflix I'm curious
um how much you guys uh thought about
online other online platforms so what
I'm thinking of is like e-commerce
platforms where you're talking about the
diversity of like vendors and uh you
have other variables like you know the
price of particular artifacts and not
just like a like a subscription price
and then also um another thing I'm
thinking about is
um uh social media platforms where um
you have like user generated content and
so
um it seems like just like qualitatively
reflecting on it it seems like those are
platforms where like if you think of
like Tick Tock or YouTube uh people
actually like there's a lot of
homogenization that happens on these
platforms like people will uh conform to
like Trends or all like collapse into
like you know single genres for a period
of time
um that things are popular so that they
can
uh accumulate or pick up users that seem
to like similar things that for periods
of time versus diversify so I'm just
curious about how much of this is like
dependent on the characteristics of the
platform and um or if there's something
about like sort of these like
subscription-based media distribution
platforms that like Drew you guys
specifically
um yeah sorry that was a big question
but uh yeah so let me try to kind of
break that down into a few things so I
guess
um maybe the easiest is talking about uh
kind of like having prices there's no
prices yeah so
I would intuitively think that
that I mean it might change some of the
profit results I'd intuitively think
that like it's not going to make a huge
difference to the phenomena you see but
but that's kind of speculation I think
the things that make bigger differences
are the other two things you mentioned
right so I guess one other attribute of
the e-commerce case is that sellers are
actually selling physical Goods so
there's an actual cost per good rather
than this one-time cost I think that can
change things potentially a lot
um especially for things like uh user
utility uh right so in some sense like I
actually wanted to be the case that
there's you know some big company that
invested like a ton in this movie that
can be amortized across you know
millions of people because then the
movie is going to be higher quality
um and so like kind of you know the
movie industry like kind of naturally
tends towards like a sort of small
number of companies you might have a
much larger set of suppliers once
there's like non-fixed costs of
production
um so I think that could change things a
lot and then your final point I think is
super for interest in on kind of
homogenization I think you are
intuitively right that
competition especially between platforms
although potentially also if you have
kind of learning Dynamics can create
periods of homogenization
um we're doing some follow-up work to
try to model some of those effects I'm
sorry if you happen to chat offline if
you want to hear more about that
I think one last question and then we'll
take
foreign
yeah actually my question is about the
learning aspects of it like um because
you there are some of these like
piecewise equilibria and so on and so
forth like it looks like there's very
interesting Behavior so I wonder if you
guys have tried things like using simple
learning algorithms or like
multiplicative weights or something like
do you also does it I don't know does it
affect like the kinds of equilibria you
converge to or yeah so so we only like
very recently started thinking about
this
um I guess what I can say is that uh
things actually Things become I think
more complicated once you have Learners
so in fact even what you converge to uh
okay even if I say everyone's a No
Regret learner
uh uh it seems although I like we really
just started thinking about this but it
seems like you can converge to different
things depending on like how quickly one
side versus the other uh like Hazard
regret decaying so I think basically
like equilibrium become much more
complicated in the learning set in
um
that
that that's about all I kind of know is
that it seems more complicated but I I
think it's a good question
okay we'll take further questions
offline thank you very much
well we have a tea break now and we'll
resume at four o'clock